Wir wollen nach acht Spieltagen auf die 2. Bundesliga der Männer schauen, explizit auf den Karlsruher SC und Hannover 96. Und das tun wir jetzt mit Steffi Baczyk vom RBB und Jörn Kreuzer.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ihr kennt mich hier aus dem Rasenfunk, aber sonst eventuell auch von 11 Freunden am Morgen und ich freue mich sehr mit zwei wundervollen Gästen über die zumindest ja kurioseste 2. Liga oder Liga der Welt zu sprechen. Zum einen darf ich in dieser Runde Steffi Baczyk begrüßen, die treue Rasenfunk-HörerInnen und auch Radio-HörerInnen sowieso kennen und auch Sportschauschauerinnen und die glücklicherweise ein bisschen Zeit für uns freischaufeln konnte. Hallo Steffi.
Hallo, für die beste 2. Liga aller Zeiten, die definitiv in dieser saison stattfindet, immer.
Und auch Gast Nummer 2 ist euch spätestens durch Staffel 1 und 2 von Haus auf Karlsruhe bekannt. Hast du dir JRR. Kreuzer eigentlich als Künstlernamen eintragen lassen, Jörn, oder wie sieht es aus?
Das wäre eine gute Idee, aber ja, ich bin mal gespannt, was der Plot hergibt für Staffel 3. Da gibt es zumindest eine kleine Fortsetzung.
Da sind wir auch schon mal sehr gespannt. Kleiner Hinweis auf ein bisschen später in dieser Folge. Aber bevor wir loslegen, schon mal eine ganz kleine Ankündigung, die euch hoffentlich nicht davon abpeilt, jetzt weiter zuzuhören. Dass ich hier heute sitze, ist gleichzeitig so ein bisschen der Startschuss für eine kleine Neuheit für diesen Teil der Ligatur auf jeden Fall. Alle zwei Wochen werdet ihr bis auf weiteres und so der Technik-Gott etc., das alles so zulässt, nicht Max, sondern abwechselnd Mark Schwitzki und mich hier als Moderatorinnen und Moderator hören. Wir freuen uns sehr, dass Max uns hier die Möglichkeit gegeben hat und den Platz überlassen hat, um über diese Liga zu sprechen. Und wir freuen uns natürlich auf die saison mit euch, aber freuen uns natürlich auch auf euer Feedback im Forum, wie euch das gefällt etc. So, jetzt aber los und bevor wir reinstarten in Derby-Schmachen, wilde Spielverläufe, wollen wir erst mal auf die Lage der Liga schauen. Jörn, was gibt es denn aus deiner Sicht spannendes zu berichten bisher?
Spannendes zu berichten ist, dass hat mir tatsächlich meine Kollegin, die Fortuna-Fan ist, dass Fortuna Ditteldorf tatsächlich zum ersten Mal seit 21 Ligaspielen am letzten Wochenende verloren hat. Die waren 21 Spiele wohl ungeschlagen, dann ausgerechnet gegen den HSV. Das wäre aus meiner Sicht der erste Punkt, den ich so mitgebracht habe, dass über den HSV dieses Jahr gefühlt gar nicht so viel gesprochen wird, sondern dass sie sich ganz gemütlich so ein bisschen unterm Radar da jetzt rangerobbt haben durch die letzten Spiele, unter anderem durch den Auswärtsweg in Düsseldorf. Und das kann diesem aufgewühlten und aufwühlenden Verein, glaube ich, nur ganz gut tun aus deren Perspektive, dass die da so ein bisschen Ruhe haben. Man spricht eher über Hertha, man spricht eher über Klose in Nürnberg, aber weniger dieses Jahr über Baumgart und den HSV. Und das zweite Team, das sich auch festgesetzt hat, fast schon heimlich, still und leise, ist der SC Paderborn aus meiner Sicht. Die liefern sehr starke Spiele ab, haben beispielsweise bei Hertha gewonnen, glaube ich, haben einen Punkt in Hamburg mitgenommen, haben jetzt souverän gewonnen. Und die stehen völlig zurecht oben in der Spitzengruppe.
Ja, ich war beim ersten Spiel von Paderborn gegen die Hertha dabei. Das war sehr souveräne Sieg. Ich habe sie auch tatsächlich gegen Hannover gesehen, in Paderborn auch da. Also, ist halt einfach eine sehr abgezockte Mannschaft und die glaube ich auch immer sehr gut irgendwie im Hintergrund agieren kann. Die hat irgendwie immer keiner so richtig auf dem Zettel, obwohl sie irgendwie seit Jahren da immer wieder oben mitspielen. Ich glaube, das ist auch schon eine gewisse Qualität, ich sage mal auch das ruhige Umfeld, dass sie da auf jeden Fall mitnehmen. Ich habe tatsächlich noch ein Spiel vom Wochenende über, das ich ganz kurz noch reden möchte, weil die beiden Vereine jetzt hier heute nicht sonst auftauchen und das ist das Spiel zwischen dem 1. FC Magdeburg und der Spielvereinigung führt. Weil ich sage ganz ehrlich, sowas habe ich in meinen 20 Jahren als Fußballfan definitiv noch nicht gesehen. Auch Alex Torneger meinte, er hätte es in 600 Spielen als trainer oder als aktiver Person im Fußball noch nicht gesehen. Kurze Schilderung der Szene erst, also erst in der ersten Hälfte passt der 4. Torhüter Neu den Ball zu Gideon Jung, also seinem Innenverteidiger, und der nimmt den Ball halt einfach in die Hand. Also man dachte anscheinend, dass es irgendwie neue Spielszenen gab. Dann natürlich Handelfmeter, durfte er nicht. Und wenn man der Schuss wird dann auch erst gehalten, erst im Nachschuss trifft dann eben Magdeburg. Wenn man dachte so ja, okay, alles klar, schon kurios genug. 42. Minute, denkt sich Magdeburg, was ihr könnt, können wir schon lange. Massimour wird irgendwie gefault und dann nimmt aber Heber, glaube ich, den Ball schon in die Hand, bevor der Schiedsrichter überhaupt irgendwas pfeifen kann. Und auch das war dann Elfmeter. Also ich war durchaus, ich war amüsiert, ich sag so. Aber Steffi, ganz kurz, gibt es bei dir, irgendwie wenn du auf die Tabelle guckst, irgendwelche Überraschungen, was du vielleicht so nicht erwartet hattest?
Ja, was ich ganz schön finde, ist, weil du den 1. FC Magdeburg gerade angesprochen hast. Die machen ja im Grunde genommen so von der mutigen Art und Weise da weiter, wo sie in der letzten saison aufgehört haben, hatten aber in der letzten Spielzeit oft auch nicht das Spielglück auf ihrer Seite. Also da gab es mal Duelle, die ich gesehen habe, zum Beispiel auch bei Hertha BSC, wo ich dachte, wow, das ist mein Team, das möchte mitmachen, die wollen einfach und haben sich ganz oft dann im Nachhinein geärgert. Und ich muss ehrlich zu euch sein, ich habe mir die Tabelle vorher angeguckt und dachte, oh, Magdeburg ist ja auch so weit oben, wie kommt das denn? Und dann im Nachhinein gesehen, wo ist die Tabelle, ich habe es ja mal herausgesucht, dass sowohl Magdeburg als auch Paderborn, als auch der KSC, über den wir heute noch sprechen werden, noch keine saisonniederlage kassiert hat. Auch das finde ich jetzt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt wirklich ganz interessant. Ihr habt Paderborn schon angesprochen. Die finde ich auch wirklich wahnsinnig stabil. Da merkt man, dass ein Team, das zusammengeblieben ist. Und Fortuna Düsseldorf finde ich ganz, ganz spannend, weil die natürlich die Abgänge gut kompensiert haben. Das merkst du jetzt, na? Also Christos Zollis, gerade für den FC Brügge ja in der Champions League unter der Woche noch getroffen, wirklich jetzt Traumtor erzielt da. Riesending, 22 Tore, Mann aus der letzten saison. Und das war ja nicht der Einzige, der gegangen ist. Und dass du dann doch immer noch so gut funktionierst, ist für mich ein Aufstiegskandidat. Lies Hannover 96 habe ich ja jetzt gar nicht mehr gerade erwähnt. Aber da kommen wir ja noch dazu.
Genau, ja ich muss sagen, kleiner Spoiler auch schon mal. Ich hatte Karlsruhe und Hannover tatsächlich in einem anderen Format als meine Aufstiegskandidaten getippt. Bitte enttäusch mich nicht. Sehr löblich, Eva. Also nachdem ich mich ja schon, nachdem sehe ich jetzt schon Leute das Maus heraus, und können über meine Bundesligatabellentipps hier im Rasenfunk zurecht Augsburg auf Platz 6 ist auch immer noch diskussionswürdig. Hoffe ich, dass ich hiermit nicht so viele Kontroversen ja angefangen habe. Aber dann lass doch mal tatsächlich reinstarten. Beim ersten Verein aus der Karlsruhe SC, wenn wir in der Tabelle lang gehen, sind jetzt nach dem letzten Spieltag zwar auf Platz 4 abgerutscht, aber Steffi hat es eben schon gesagt. 16 Punkte, damit eben auch punktgleich mit Magdeburg und Paderborn. Alle drei Vereine ohne Niederlage. Die letzten Ergebnisse, die waren allerdings ein bisschen wild. 4 zu 4 gegen den 1. FC Köln auswärts, sondern 3 zu 3 gegen Darmstadt. In zwei Spielen hat man dann so viele Gegentore kassiert, wie vorher in sechs Spielen, wenn ich das richtig recherchiert habe. Aber generell Offensive ist, glaube ich, ganz gut unterwegs. Gemeinsam mit dem HSV stellt man die zweitbeste Offensive, die beste Städtejugend der SC Köln. Jörn, nimm uns mal mit in diesen bisherigen saisonsverlauf. Vielleicht erst mal ausklammern die beiden letzten Ergebnisse. Wie waren die ersten sechs Spiele denn, das Sportliche mal draufzuschauen?
Zum einen waren sie erst mal überraschend, weil man muss sehen, Christian Eichner hat im Sommer davon geredet, dass er schon Bauchgrummeln hat, in die saison zu gehen. Jetzt nicht wegen der Qualität der Neuzugänge, vor allem aber auch wegen der Quantität und Qualität der Abgänge. Ich fand den Umbruch im Sommer relativ krass. Man darf nicht vergessen, dass mit Paul Nebel aus meiner Perspektive einer der besten Spieler der zweiten Liga gegangen ist. Der war gegen den Ball schon immer gut, war dann in der letzten Rückrunde auch plötzlich mit Ball gut, wurde torgefährlich. Ich glaube, den hätten mainz ganz gut gebrauchen können, schon letztes Jahr. Matanowicz ist zur Eintracht zurückgegangen. Den hat Christian Eichner auch super hinbekommen. Gondorf, der Kapitän der Jahre lang, hat seine Karriere beendet. Stindl hat seine Karriere beendet. Der war jetzt nur ein Jahr da, aber trotzdem war er eine wichtige Figur. Und, was auch viele vergessen, Patrick Greves, unumstrittener Nummer-1-Torhüter, ist zum VfL Bochum gegangen. Von daher dachte ich, oh, mal schauen. Aber am Ende ist es tatsächlich so, dass sich aktuell wieder Gianni Costa in der letzten Folge, glaube ich, schon erwähnt hat, Kontinuität aktuell auszeichnet. Kontinuität vor allem auf der trainerbank mit Christian Eichner. Ich glaube, er ist der Dienstälteste in der zweiten Liga. Dadurch hat er eine Kontinuität in die Mannschaft bekommen, die mich ein bisschen staunend zurückließ. Ich bin zum Beispiel zum Pokalspiel nach Lotte gefahren. Jetzt haben sie 5 zu 0 gewonnen und ich dachte mir, okay, viertelig ist, da kann man als Zweites gut stolpern. Aber wie die das runtergespielt haben, war faszinierend. Jeder weiß, was er auf dem Feld zu machen hat. Die spielen das diszipliniert runter. Es gibt kleine Rückschläge. Es ist völlig egal. Die spielen ihr Level runter. Sie lassen sich durch nichts erschüttern. Das waren so die Eindrücke der ersten saisonspiele. Ich war dann auch noch Anfang September in Braunschweig. Selbe Situation. Braunschweig enormen Unterdruck. Geht 1-0 in Führung. Und ich hatte im Gästeblock gar nicht das Gefühl, dass da was andrennen kann an dem Tag. Weil die haben das so diszipliniert, so ruhig runtergespielt. Einfach, man muss es so sagen, im Stile einer Spitzenmannschaft. Und deshalb stehen sie auch aktuell da oben. Und jeder kennt in diesem Kader seinen Platz. Also, das fängt an mit Robin Himmelmann, dem Ersatztorwart, der dem Max Weiß so ein bisschen Unterstützung liefern kann. Cennis Burnic, Eichner redet immer davon, das ist ein Frank-Schmidt-Spieler. Und bei allen kommt sofort was in den Kopf, was ein Frank-Schmidt-Spieler ist. Der macht 90 Minuten, fleißig diszipliniert seine Arbeit. Und wenn 120 Minuten gehen muss, macht er es auch. Genau. Und tatsächlich, ich glaube, in sieben von acht saisonspielen jetzt haben wir dieselbe Elf gehabt auf dem Feld. 4-4-2, immer dieselben Spieler. Und das ist ein großes Faustband. Was jetzt nicht passieren darf, Verletzungen.
Ja, aber dann lass uns einmal doch noch mal auf diese letzten beiden Spiele gucken. Also ich glaube, das 4-4 gegen Köln, da stand es, glaube ich, gefühlt nach 30 Minuten schon 3-0 für den FC. Und dann kann man das nach 15. Ja, richtig. Ich weiß, ich hatte mit einem Kölner Freund von mir geschrieben und hatte da tatsächlich so gesagt, na dann fiel nämlich das 3-1 für Karlsruhe. Und dann meinte ich ihr macht einfach das das 4-1. Und dann ist die Geschichte durch. Und dann meinte er so Pass mal auf. Und dann kam eben auch diese Aufholjagd. Ich glaube, das kann man ja eher als gewonnenen Punkt hinterher durchaus sehen, einfach vom Spielverlauf her. Aber dieses 3-3 gegen Darmstadt, da war glaube ich Eichner hinterher auch ordentlich angefressen und hat eben gesagt, man hat sich zwischendurch komplett neutralisiert, hat überhaupt nichts mehr gemacht. Wie würdest du diese beiden letzten Spiele einsortieren? Also gerade auch, weil defensiv ja dann doch ein bisschen was schiefgelaufen ist.
Ja, genau, da sprichst du quasi den Punkt an. Und das hat Eichner oder Christian Eichner hat das auch direkt gesagt nach der Pressekonferenz, auch an den Mikros, dass ihm die Defensivarbeit der letzten zwei Spiele überhaupt nicht gefallen hat. Wenn was tatsächlich in den letzten 1,5, 2 Jahren eine Achillesverse ist, dann ist es das defensive Verhalten, die defensive Stabilität, auch eine gewisse naivität bei Eckbällen. Ich glaube, das war das dritte Tor von Darmstadt. Das ist halt relativ simpel. Da verliert der Innenverteidiger den anderen Innenverteidiger aus den Augen und dann klingelt es direkt. Und das war tatsächlich so alte Probleme, die wir eigentlich schon kennen. Dass man so ein bisschen zu leicht Tore kassiert, defensiv zu instabil ist. Das kannte man aus den ersten sechs Spielen so nicht in der Form. Da waren auch zu null Spiele dabei. Und dementsprechend gilt es da anzusetzen, weil alles andere passt super. Wie die sich ins letzte Drittel durchspielen. Max wird das nicht gerne hören. Karlsruhe trifft extrem oft durch Flanken aktuell. Ich glaube schon 8 Tore oder so. Aber ja, es ist einfach wunderbar. Also die spielen sich zur Grundlinie durch, haben die Option, in die Mitte zu gehen, aber auch zurückzulegen, weil damit Burnitz, Jensen und Warnizek extrem starke Abschlussspieler stehen im Rückraum.
Ich glaube, Max hat ja dann auch kein Problem damit. Du war ganz kurz vorhin das mit Flanken. Solange die reingehen, ist ja alles super. Wenn er gefüttert wird, ohne dass da irgendein Output ist, dann wird er angry.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich kann sagen, als Fan eines war eins, die gefühlt 45 Flanken pro Spiel schlagen, von der ungefähr 0,5 ankommen, gefühlt, gefühlt, kann ich also, ich mutiere manchmal ein bisschen als Max 2.0, wenn ich da im Stadion stehe und denke so, nee, nee, bitte nicht schon wieder. Aber wenn wir jetzt nochmal auf die Defensive schauen, also ich habe eben schon gesagt, Offensive braucht man, glaube ich, nicht viel zu sprechen. Aber wenn man eben auch auf den Liga-Vergleich guckt oder gerade eben an der Spitze der Tabelle in den Vergleich guckt, fällt ja schon aus, das ist dann schon auch die schlechteste Defensive. Und klar, das sind jetzt nur zwei Spieler, aber wir wissen alle, so ein Torverhältnis, das kann dann auch gerade zum Ende der saison, das kann nochmal Ausschlag geben sein. Wenn du sagst, das ist seit mehreren Jahren dann doch immer wieder Thema, hast du das Gefühl, das wird zwischendurch vermehrt angegangen, das wird personell angegangen oder hast du das Gefühl, das ist manchmal einfach so ein psychisches Ding, dass man das nicht ganz rauskriegt?
Ich denke, es ist vor allem eine Mischung von allem. Am Ende ist es wahrscheinlich so ein Konglomerat aus allen, weil man hat auch gesagt, nach dem 0-0 in Düsseldorf war das so ein Kopföffner für die Mannschaft, dass es klappen kann, auch gegen starke Mannschaften. Jetzt haben sie auch, wenn man Magdeburg mit dazunimmt, eben auch neun Tore kassiert in drei Spielen. Deshalb tut die Länderspielpause gar nicht so schlecht, glaube ich. Es sind auch so simple Sachen teilweise. Also in Köln das zweite Tor, das ist einfach nur ein langer Ball von der Mittellinie, der in die Schnittstelle gespielt wird, wo sie einfach nicht gut zueinander positioniert sind. Daran kann man schon ansetzen, also finde ich. Also man muss daran arbeiten, auch die Konzentration im Kopf wieder hochfahren, definitiv. Man darf aber auch nicht vergessen, dass wir im Endeffekt auf der Position nur den Massel Beifuß haben, den Massel Franke und aktuell den Kobalt, weil Robin Bormuth verletzt ist. Dementsprechend hat man eigentlich gar keine Variante. Das war tatsächlich der einzige Wechsel bisher in der Startelf, dass einmal Kobalt für Franke gespielt hat. Also im Endeffekt muss man auf die Jungs setzen und da den Hebel finden. Das hat ja auch schon geklappt.
Aber wenn du da jetzt ansprichst, dass da vielleicht auch so ein bisschen den Alternativen fehlen, würdest du da so ein leichtes Versäumnis auf dem Transfermarkt attestieren oder ist das eine klare Vorgabe auch von Aichner, dass man da den Kader eher knapper als dann vielleicht an einer Stelle zu überfüllt halten soll?
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Da müsste man auf jeden Fall ansetzen, dass man da was holen muss. Aber es müsste dann halt definitiv jemand sein, der sofort helfen kann und Innenverteidiger, das ist schon immer ein Thema. Das ist schon immer ein Thema. Das hat sich die letzten Jahre durchgezogen. Wir hatten eigentlich einen recht interessanten Ansatz einmal mit O'Shaughnessy, der kam aus Helsinki. Der hat dann fünf überragende Spiele gemacht, hat sich verletzt und wurde nie mehr gesehen. Also de facto.
Ich verändere mich.
Und dessen Vertrag ist jetzt zum Beispiel im Sommer ausgelaufen. Aus der Jugend kommt aktuell auch nicht so viel nach, sage ich mal. Und mein Eindruck war, dass man sich jetzt im Sommer vor allem erst mal auf die Position Außen so ein bisschen konzentriert hat. Also man hat Lasse Günther geholt und Heroldfest verpflichtet. Also Außen ist es jetzt ganz gut. Und die nächste Baustelle wäre jetzt tatsächlich in der Verteidigung.
Okay, das ist dann ja wahrscheinlich erstmal was für die Winterpause, weil ich könnte mir halt schon vorstellen, also ich kann mir halt schon vorstellen, dass Karlsruhe bis zum Ende oben dran bleibt. Aber man muss halt, also wir haben es glaube ich, ja wir haben eben kurz über den HSV geredet, die gerade zum Ende der saison dann immer wieder so Spiele drin hatten, wo man eigentlich sagt, das müssen sie, wenn auch knapp, gewinnen. Und dann ist halt ein individueller Fehler hinten, der das irgendwie so ein bisschen ausmärzt. Also könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass wenn man dann doch irgendwann zur Winterpause sieht, okay, hey, also wir haben eigentlich Qualität im Kader, offensiv ist kein Problem, aber wir verlieren halt die Spiele wirklich durch die Defensive. Dann könnte ich mir schon auch durchaus vorstellen, dass man ja vielleicht da das dann auch nochmal irgendwie ein bisschen mehr fokussiert. Aber wie du schon sagst, das bringt natürlich auch nichts, wenn das dann so ein, ich sag mal, Perspektivspieler ist, wo man sagt, ja okay, der könnte vielleicht mal in drei Spielen in der saison helfen, sondern das müsste dann natürlich schon eine Soforthilfe sein.
Und den hat man ja de facto mit Marcel Beifuß geholt. Der ist aktuell Stammspieler, aber es ist ein totaler Lernprozess. Das merkt man halt bei ihm extrem. Also der hat super gute Spiele, solide Spiele, da redet keiner über ihn. Jetzt hat er da auf den Innenverteidiger von Darmstadt nicht aufgepasst– bei dem einen Eckball im letzten Spiel ist es passiert –,Aber tatsächlich ist Marcel Weikus für mich so ein typisches Beispiel eines jungen Spielers, der einfach permanent lernt und der halt da rangeführt wird. Und er wird jetzt halt dadurch rangeführt, dass er spielen muss die ganze Zeit. Wir hatten andere Themen im Sommer, das war beispielsweise Sturm. Im Sturm war immer extrem viel Druck. Wer ersetzt denn jetzt Matanowicz und so weiter und so fort? De facto ersetzt den gerade keiner, sondern es ist aus rauseigene Mitteln sozusagen. Mit Schleusener und Zivcivatze.
Ich finde halt bei Zivcivatze ganz spannend, weil ich habe schon irgendwie das Gefühl, dass gerade auch die EM, der Blick auf Georgien, der hat sich schon so ein bisschen verändert eventuell. Und ich habe auch so das Gefühl, er hat auch diesen Schwung, weil wir haben ja auf jeden Fall auch eine gute EM gespielt, dafür, dass es ihre erste war. Man hatte schon so gerade am Anfang der saison das Gefühl, dass er jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen mehr zeigen will. Also, wie würdest du ihn auch bewerten?
Ja, Boudou ist so ein bisschen lustig, weil ich hatte mir im Sommer fast schon gedacht, dass Boudou Tsiftziwadze quasi in Anführungszeichen der Verlegenheitskauf, Wintereinkauf von Oliver Kreuzer werden könnte, der Millionen im Karlsruher SC bringt. Weil das war ja auch ein Vormurph, als Oliver Kreuzer rausflog, dass er mit Spielern keine Kohle gemacht hat. Und Boudou wäre so ein Kandidat gewesen, der Geld hätte bringen können. Es kam dann nicht so. Ich glaube, man ist auch total auf ihn angewiesen, dass er spielt. Es gab ganz kurz vor der Schließung des Transferfensters plötzlich eine Meldung, dass es ein Millionenangebot gibt in der Presse. Und der Journalist musste dann zwei Tage später schreiben, ich habe einen super krassen Informant, der war jahrelang zuverlässig, jetzt hat er mir mal Quatsch erzählt, der Boudou hat gar kein Angebot gehabt. Aber es ist auch vom Typ her, der macht total Spaß. Und was ich auch krass aktuell finde, bei jedem Spiel vom KSC ganz viele georgische Farben. Die fahren dahin und wollen den sehen und wollen den abklatschen. Das ist wirklich bemerkenswert gewesen. Das waren in Braunspeik mindestens 50 Leute.
Das ist auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert.
Ja, er macht Spaß, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde bei Karlsruhe auch immer wieder spannend. Ich finde es immer schon sehr unangenehm, Gegner auch zu bespielen, vor allem Untereichner, weil sie eben, also man hat schon irgendwie das Gefühl, da ist trotzdem bis zum Ende immer die Möglichkeit da. Also sie eben auch dieses Kölnspiel, klar muss man darüber reden, wie schafft man es in 15 Minuten, so komplett einmal umzugehen. Aber ich meine, sie haben es halt zurück geschafft und das fand ich schon durchaus bemerkenswert. Und vielleicht kommt jetzt auch die Länderspielpause zum richtigen Zeitpunkt, um da eben doch noch mal an ein, zwei Stellen dran zu bauen. Also ich sag mal, so besser jetzt als, ich meine, die Phase jetzt bis zur Winterpause ist dann ja doch noch eine etwas längere, bis sie dann kommt da. Und also wie gesagt, ich glaube, es gibt wenig trainer, die da durchaus auch die richtigen Worte finden, die ich dann gehört habe, aber definitiv dazu, von meiner Warte aus.
Das auf jeden Fall und vielleicht kann ich noch eine Ergänzung machen, was auch wichtig war, was ich, was man vielleicht ein bisschen unterschätzt hat oder schade fand, dass mit Gondorf so eine wichtige Hierarchiefigur weggegangen ist. Aber man hat es extrem schnell geschafft, eine neue Hierarchie aufzubauen und war mit Warnizek, wie der in diese Kapitänsrolle reingewachsen ist, in allerkürzester Zeit. Das ist fantastisch. Also der muss auch irgendwie in der Kabine auf den Tisch gehauen haben in Köln. Das hat ja offensichtlich Wirkung gezeigt. Also so ein Spieler, den kann man sich nicht schnitzen, den wünschen sich alle, kommt aus der Gegend, will eigentlich nicht wechseln, liebt den KSC, scoort und ist jetzt auch Kapitän. Das ist Wahnsinn. Tim von Millantown ist immer neidisch. Er hätte nämlich gern bei Mächtig San Pauli, wenn ich mal mit ihm drüber spreche. Ja, ein toller Spieler, aber auch sehr wichtig, dass die Hierarchie funktioniert.
Obwohl ich tatsächlich immer bei so Spielern wie Vanicek, wenn du sagst, San Pauli ist dann ja doch immer so der Schritt von der 2. Liga zur Bundesliga. Der ist dann ja doch schon immer auch so die Marcel Hartels und so dieser Welt, die eigentlich spielerisch immer so einen Tick zu gut waren für die 2. Liga, aber einfach dann in der Bundesliga nicht mehr die Zeit bekommen, um eben auch diese Schlüsselmomente auszuleben. Wie siehst du denn generell die Chancen für den KSC? Also wird da irgendwas formuliert Richtung Ausstieg? Gibt es da, also man muss ja eh sagen, diese Zeiten, das wird vor der saison in der Pressekonferenz gesagt, hier Platz 1 bis 6, ist ja meistens doch eher vorbei, weil die alle anwesenden oder alle ja irgendwie auch gelernt haben, das fliegt uns am Ende der saison nur um die Ohren. Aber gibt es da Äußerungen vom KSC dahingehend, wo man sich festsetzen will?
Also Christian Eichner, also die lassen sich natürlich nicht locken, lassen sich aber dennoch in die Karten schauen. Also man ist schon selbstbewusst genug zu sagen, wir haben tolle Kontinuität, guten trainer, es läuft, auch die letzte Rückrunde war schon nicht schlecht. Aber es müssen tatsächlich gerade beim KSC verschiedene Faktoren zusammenkommen. Es dürfen Schlüsselspieler auf keinen Fall ausfallen. Und es muss tatsächlich auch weiterhin Spiele geben, die jetzt in der Vergangenheit mal zum Gegner gekippt sind, die eher zu uns kippen. Dann kann es sehr lange, können die oben mit dabei bleiben. Ich weiß aber, dass sie eine unfassbare Ruhe haben und kontinuitierlich weiterarbeiten. Und dementsprechend kann es weit gehen. Wie weit, hängt auch ein Stück weit von der Konferenz ab. Man muss natürlich sagen, man schaut immer auf sich selbst. Klar, aber ja. Ich fand auch, die drei Spiele waren die Länderspielpause. Und danach kamen mit Schalke, Magdeburg, Köln so drei Schwergewichte, sage ich mal, oder halt große Vereine und Magdeburg eher überraschend oben. Und das haben sie ganz gut gemeistert, haben nicht verloren. Das war jetzt ein bisschen glücklich, aber durch diese Phase sind sie auch gekommen. Jetzt werden wir mal sehen.
Ja, also am Ende ist es ja, also blöd gesagt, aber am Ende der saison fragt dich dann auch niemand, wenn da steht, weiß ich nicht, drei Niederlagen in der ganzen saison. Frag dich halt niemand, ja, aber warum stehen da nicht mehr, sondern es zählen halt nur die Punkte. Und ja, dann sind solche Spiele auf jeden Fall wichtig und ja, vielleicht auch besser jetzt diese Spiele zu haben als eben in einer kritischen Phase zum Ende der saison. Lass uns einmal kurz, außer du möchtest da jetzt gerade noch zu was loswerden, lass uns einmal kurz auf das Thema Haus auf Karlsruhe, also auf das Umfeld schauen. Du hast eben schon mal angedeutet, es gibt vielleicht so ein kleines Spin-Off, so ganz leicht, nicht mehr das ganz große Drama, aber wie sieht denn das Karlsruher Umfeld gerade aus?
Na ja, vielleicht noch zu der Vizepräsidenten-Geschichte. Ich glaube, das war das letzte Mal, als ich beim Rasenfunk zu Gast war. Da standen die Mitgliederversammlungen quasi vor der Tür. Da gab es dann gegenseitige Abwahlanträge im Präsidium. Die wurden dann quasi per Beschluss zurückgezogen, weil im Endeffekt der Mitgliederrat oder Vorsitzende des Mitgliederrates, was ganz schlau uns gesagt hat, der hat gesagt, ey, wenn wir uns jetzt gegenseitig abwählen, haben wir kein funktionierendes Präsidium mehr. Das ist doch auch blöd. Die wurden dann zurückgezogen. Allerdings wurde der Vizepräsident Martin Müller nicht entlastet, hat dann auch wenig Reue gezeigt und hat dann auch so eine andere, so diese Aktionärsversammlung so ein bisschen dazu genutzt, um da wieder Unfrieden zu stiften. Dann war es dem Mitgliederrat zu viel. Der hat dann gesagt, okay, wir beantragen, eine außerordentliche Mitgliederversammlung in ihm abzuwählen, weil ihm wurden verschiedene goldene Brücken gebaut. Die hat er nicht erkannt, sollte nicht drübergehen, was auch immer. Die gab es dann im Frühjahr mit 61 Prozent wurde er dann abgewählt. Es gab dann natürlich auch eine starke Fraktion Pro-Müller, die meinte, es sei alles ungerechtfertigt, diese MV einzuberufen und so weiter und so fort. Das ging da auch noch vor Gericht. Das hat das Gericht dann abgeschmettert. Das war alles rechtmäßig einberufen und so weiter. Und dann wurde jetzt im Juni, glaube ich, Mario Eggemann mit großer Mehrheit gewissermaßen zum Vizepräsidenten gewählt, der unter anderem auch eine Hannover-Rahner-Vergangenheit hat, aber speziell beim KSC auch zur Aufstiegsmannschaft gehört. Dementsprechend hat man jetzt mit Sebastian Freis, Christian Eichner, Mario Eggemann, Markus Miller als torwarttrainer und Martin Stoll, u17-trainer– vielleicht habe ich auch einen vergessen– eine sehr große Fraktion der Aufstiegsmannschaft 2006, 2007 im Verein. In unterschiedlichen Funktionen. Und seitdem ist auf der Baustelle so ein Stück weit Ruhe. Nichtsdestotrotz habe ich den Eindruck, dass quasi dieses Lager Müller immer noch so ein bisschen versucht, Einfluss zu nehmen, ist aber ganz schwierig zu fassen. Also es ist auch eher so ein Eindruck von mir. Also, ja, dass man eben versucht, Sebastians Freis Arbeit so ein bisschen zu konterkarieren, kriegt ja keine Spieler ran und so weiter und so fort, obwohl man das ja eigentlich noch gar nicht seriös bewerten kann. Also Sebastians Freis Arbeit kann man in ein, zwei Jahren bewerten, wenn man mal so ein, zwei Transferzyklen durchgemacht hat.
Okay, ich finde es auf jeden Fall spannend, weil ich glaube, es tut Karlsruhe generell dann doch auch gut, wenn da auch mal Ruhe einkehrt. Aber Thema Ruhe ist dann ja doch auch nicht so ganz. Also wenn wir, also so ruhig, wie es da ist, gibt es ja doch durchaus auch viele Medienberichte über den KSC, was gar nicht mal so mit der mit Aufsichtsrat und Co. zu tun hat, sondern ja mit Anfang, glaube ich, eine Pyroshow zu 20 Jahren Reihenfeier im November 2022 gegen St. Pauli, wo unter anderem Menschen verletzt wurden und deshalb ja einfach ein Gerichtsverfahren oder mehrere Gerichtsverfahren gegen KSC Ultras oder Mitglieder der organisierten Fanszene begonnen wurden. Ich glaube, auch heute gab es ein weiteres Verfahren. Bis jetzt wurden acht Urteile gesprochen. 25 stehen aus. Und jetzt vor zwei Wochen, 19. September, wurden zwei KSC-Fans vom Amtsgericht Karlsruhe zur Haftstrafe verurteilt. So viel dazu, erstmal grob das Umrissen, was der Ursprung ist, was so, glaube ich, schon so der letzte Stand ist. Und jetzt ist ja, glaube ich, nächste Woche sollen die Sozial-, die Mitarbeiter des Fanprojekts, glaube ich, vor Gericht aussagen. Ist das richtig?
Ja, also die stehen selber vor Gericht, gewissermaßen. Genau, weil das ist quasi ein Komplex der ganzen Geschichte, dass die sich quasi an, also die wollten quasi keine Leute verpfeifen, weil sie dann aus ihrer Perspektive bzw. halt gesagt hätten, okay, dann können wir unsere Arbeit nicht mehr machen, weil das Vertrauensverhältnis in der sozialen Arbeit muss einfach gewahrt sein. Sie haben sich strikt dagegen geweigert, mit der Staatsanwaltschaft zu kooperieren und mit der Polizei. Und dementsprechend stand sogar irgendwann beugerhaft im Raum. Die wurde dann quasi doch nicht vollstreckt, sondern die Lösung aus Sicht der Staatsanwaltschaft Karlsruhe war dann Tagessätze a 60 Euro, 120 Stück. Und dagegen haben sie jetzt wieder Widerspruch eingelegt und dementsprechend müssen wir deshalb vor Gericht erscheinen. Was vielleicht noch eine spannende Ergänzung, gerade vorgestern oder war es vorgestern oder gestern sogar, gab es tatsächlich eine Diskussion um Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht in der sozialen Arbeit im Stadtjugendausschuss in Karlsruhe im Arne-Frank-Haus. Das war wohl ein ganz spannend besetztes Podium, wo unter anderem auch ein Rechtswissenschaftler gesagt hat, dass sie rein vom Ethik des Berufs her alles richtig gemacht haben, dass sie sich dazu nicht geäußert haben. Der Vorsitzende des Stadtjugendausschusses hat auch gesagt, dass er da jetzt als Chef das dementsprechend nicht ahnen kann. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Prozessmenge und eine Vorgehensweise, die definitiv Auswirkungen auf den deutschen Fußball haben, auf deutsche Fußballfans. Das macht es so überregional wichtig. Gerade das mit den Fanprojektmitarbeitern, das sind natürlich alle alarmiert, alle Fanprojektmitarbeiter, die ich aus anderen Fußballvereinen kenne. Aber auch die Prozessgestaltung an sich, finde ich, ich habe da irgendwie, ich persönlich habe da ein Störgefühl. Ich war damals im Stadion gegen St. Pauli. Das war ja auch ein 4 zu 4. Und wir waren auf der anderen Seite gesessen mit der Familie. Und natürlich hat man in den ersten 15 Minuten gesehen, da ist irgendwas massiv schiefgelaufen. Es war so nasskalter Tag, Nebelentwicklung und so weiter. Aber es ist halt so in die Buchse gegangen, dass, glaube ich, allen Beteiligten klar war, dass da irgendwas, dass da Scheiße passiert ist, auf gut Deutsch. Und dass die Staatsanwaltschaft dann mehr oder weniger intrinsisch aus eigenem Antrieb ermittelt, fand ich dann schon irgendwie so, also das finde ich bemerkenswert und vor allem auch das Ausmaß, also dass man beugehaft androht und so weiter und so fort. Weil quasi die Fanprojekt-MitarbeiterInnen zu Zeugenaussagen zu nötigen oder zu zwingen, wird ja daher, dass es quasi zwischen der Fanszene und den verletzten Personen quasi so eine Art Versöhnungsgespräch gab. Ich war da nicht dabei, aber ich gehe davon aus, da wurde sich entschuldigt und so weiter und so fort und ist auch irgendwie geregelt dementsprechend. Und Tatsache bei der ganzen Geschichte ist eben auch, dass es aus dem, also das gehört auch dazu, ist auch ein Teil der Geschichte, dass es aus dem Kreis der verletzten Personen keine Anzeige gab. Also es ist quasi eine intrinsische, selbstmotivierte Aktion. Und dass man dann halt irgendwie 28 Gerichtsverfahren hat, 15 Leute stehen, glaube ich, vor Gericht, plus die drei SozialarbeiterInnen. Dann wurden jetzt zwei zu Haftstrafen ohne Bewährung verurteilt. Und da kann ich nur empfehlen, Ka-News, dieses Portal macht so eine Art pyro-eclair. Die sind dann natürlich martialisch Live-Ticker. Und wenn man dann so liest, was da teilweise als Beweis vorgeführt wird, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe da irgendwie in mir drin so ein Störgefühl, ob das irgendwie nicht zu weit geht. Oder warum das so ausgebreitet wird. Also das kann ich nicht so richtig nachvollziehen. Da steht einer vor Gericht und quasi die Beweislage ist, er war in einer Chatgruppe mit drin, war da aber nicht aktiv. Wird aber möglicherweise wegen schwerer Körperverletzung, gemeinschaftlicher schwerer Körperverletzung, verurteilt. Ich bin da juristisch zu sehr in Leih, vielleicht setze ich mich jetzt gerade auch in den Esslen, aber manche Dinge kann ich nicht marktvoll sehen.
Steffi, ganz kurz auch die Frage nur an dich, also auch wenn du da natürlich überhaupt nicht nah dran sein musst oder sonst irgendwas, aber ganz von außen betrachtet, wie bewertest du generell einfach diese Entwicklung dieses Prozesses? Also ich meine, Jörn hat es ja eigentlich ganz gut aufgezeigt, was eventuell auch die Probleme sind. Wie hast du das vielleicht auch von außerhalb so ein bisschen mitverfolgen können?
Ich muss da leider passen. Also ich habe da gar nicht so viel mitverfolgt. Deshalb, ich habe das jetzt gerade so schön aufgegliedert, das Ganze. Ich habe da ganz interessiert zugehört. Klingt auf jeden Fall sehr verworren, aber da ist es ja ganz oft bei solchen Geschichten, dass so viele Kleinigkeiten mit bedacht werden müssen. Und ich würde mich da ungern zu weit jetzt aus dem Fenster legen, um zu sagen, dass ich da irgendwelche Bewertungen anstelle, ohne die details wirklich ganz genau im Vorfeld jetzt so kennen. Das lasse ich jetzt mal beim Jörn.
Ja, ich würde nochmal auf diese Thematik, Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht für SozialarbeiterInnen generell. Ich finde es halt, also generell, das betrifft ja nicht nur den Fußball, sondern es ist ja ein großes Spektrum. Und gerade Sozialarbeiterinnen arbeiten natürlich auch viel mit jugendlichen Menschen zusammen, die so eine gewisse, also, ich will jetzt hier nicht irgendwelche Straftaten kleinreden wollen oder bitte mich nicht falsch verstehen, aber es hat natürlich einen unfassbar großen Vertrauensaspekt. Und ich muss einfach sagen, ich kann es tatsächlich von außen nicht so ganz verstehen, warum es das für SozialarbeiterInnen irgendwie noch nicht gibt. Und habe da auch wirklich meinen höchsten Respekt vor. Aber du hast es angesprochen, dieses Gespräch. Ich glaube, es war tatsächlich gestern Abend. Ich glaube, selbst der Oberbürgermeister hat mehr oder weniger gesagt, ich verstehe schon, warum sie so handeln. Also er rät ihn, glaube ich, zur Aussage, sagt aber generell, dass er ihr bisheriges Vorgehen jetzt nicht falsch findet oder verurteilt. Und das finde ich schon durchaus bemerkenswert. Und ich glaube, wie du schon sagst, je nachdem, wie das ausgeht, das kann natürlich großen Einfluss auf generell soziale Arbeit, aber natürlich jetzt auch im Speziellen auf die Arbeit der Fanprojekte haben. Und da bin ich schon durchaus gespannt, weil ich weiß nur persönlich hier in Bielefeld, was die hier für Arbeit leisten, auch im gesellschaftlichen Kontext. Was da alles mit organisiert wird für Jugendliche, aber auch im Bereich Traumaforschung und so. Das ist schon enorm. Und wenn da irgendwie dann Vertrauensverlust herrscht, für die sie ja im Endeffekt noch nicht mehr was können, das stelle ich mir nicht sonderlich schön vor. Aber genau, also danke dir auch nochmal zum Aufdröseln. Ich glaube, das wird sich noch ein bisschen ziehen. Und wir werden da sehen, ich glaube, was da am Ende rauskommt. Aber wie du schon sagst, da sind so ein paar Punkte, wo man durchaus nochmal nachgucken kann. Ich glaube, es gab auch– es sind ja in letzter Zeit mehrere Doku aus dem Thema Ultras und Kro rausgekommen, wo auch dann Leute aus dem Fanprojekt zu Wort gekommen sind und auch die Staatsanwaltschaft zu Wort gekommen ist. Also, wer möchte, kann sich das sicherlich auch nochmal angucken, was da für Zitate auch fallen und sich dann ja auch sowieso– am Ende des Tages muss sich sowieso jeder und jeder selber eine Meinung darüber bilden, aber ich glaube, wir haben es zumindest einmal ganz gut erklärt. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube, endgültig kann man sowieso erst sagen, wenn nächste Woche rum ist, aber generell auch, wenn der Prozess vollständig beendet ist. Gut, dann würde ich sagen, springen wir zum anderen Verein, zu Hannover 96. Die stehen auf Platz 6, 13 Punkte, 4 Siege, ein Unentschieden, 3 Niederlagen und vor allem die letzte Niederlage. Die tat richtig weh. Das war nämlich eine 2 zu 0 Niederlage im Derby gegen Eintracht Braunschweig. Über die Begleiterscheinung dieses Derbys, darüber erzähle ich euch nachher noch was. Aber schauen wir, und das schon mal als disclaimer, wir wollen hier heute mal ausnahmsweise, ausnahmsweise muss man wirklich sagen, an Hannover 96, vor allem auf Sportliche gucken. Das kommt ja doch durchaus ab und zu mal ein bisschen zu kurz. Und Steffi, lass uns einfach mal tatsächlich doch bei diesem Derby anfangen. 2 zu 0, ich habe es eben schon gesagt, die Zitate hinterher von allen Beteiligten auf Hannover Seite waren durchaus niederschmetternd. Also, dass man das Derby zurecht verloren hat, etc. Wie blickst du auf dieses Spiel, auf dieses Derby?
Na ja, wir wissen ja alle, dass so ein Derby, und da nimmt sich ja das Niedersachsen-Derby dann am Ende nicht raus, einfach ein besonderes Spiel ist. Und dass da natürlich immer Feuer drin ist. Und du hast ja auch schon mal so ein bisschen drauf hingetiest, dass dieses Spiel jetzt unter besonderen Vorzeichen stattgefunden hat, dass es keine Unterstützung gab von den aktiven Fanszenen auch. Aber ich hatte sportlich gesehen den Eindruck, und das kann nun mal leider Gottes passieren, und dieses Mal ist es passiert, dass Braunschweig von der ersten Minute an da war. Besser in den Zweikämpfen war, auf den zweiten Bällen war, entschlossener in den Aktionen war. Und das sind halt dann unterm Strich diese Kleinigkeiten, die ein Derby entscheiden können. Also mich hat es nicht gewundert, als Fabio Kaufmann dann das 1 zu 0 erzielt hat. Das war auch so eine typische Szene, wo du gemerkt hast, dass 96 da im Kopf einfach immer diesen Schritt zu langsam gewesen ist. Aber wirklich durchweg einmal, durch die Bank durch. Es ist natürlich umso bitterer, dass das Ganze dann in so einem Derby passiert ist. Weil wenn man Fans fragt und sagt, okay, was kannst du erreichen? Na ja, um den Aufstieg mitspielen ist ja ganz toll. Aber dann gibt es das Derby und das Derby muss gewonnen werden. Das heißt, natürlich gibt es da erst mal Katerstimmung jetzt in der niedersächsischen Landeshauptstadt. Es ging ab Ende aber zu Recht, zugunsten von Eintracht Braunschweighaus.
Ja, also zum Beispiel Leitl hat gesagt, zu viele falsche einzelnen Entscheidungen getroffen, nicht schnell genug. Was du auch gerade schon gesagt hast, keine guten Lösungen. Ron Robert Zieler war, glaube ich, richtig stinkig. Also da hatte man ihm auch noch nicht gesagt, glaube ich, dass durchaus ein paar andere Gegner um einen herum oder Mannschaften auch noch Punkte liegen gelassen haben. Also die berühmten Big-Points auch noch auf der Straße lagen, sagen wir es mal so. Er hat dann auch gesagt, es fehlen mir komplett die Worte, wie wir zu Hause so stark sein können und auswärts so bescheiden auftreten. Und das ist tatsächlich ein guter Punkt, weil ich habe eben gesagt, vier Siege und diese vier Siege, alle vier zu Hause dafür auswärts. Kein einziges Spiel gewonnen. Drei Nieler lagen auswärts, wenn man das Pokalspiel noch mitrechnet, sind es sogar vier. Ein Unentschieden beim Aufsteiger Preußen Münster. Also jetzt auch kein Übergegner bei einem Respekt vor dem Aufsteiger. Aber das finde ich schon krass. Und dass man doch durchaus so eine, ja wirklich diese Diskrepanz sieht zwischen Heim und auswärts. Also dass da wirklich so ein kompletter Unterschied ist. Klar, man spielt natürlich nicht immer gleichzeitig gegen den Verein, gegen den man heim spielt, direkt nächste Woche auswärts. Aber wie schaust du auch darauf, dass da dieser Unterschied da ist?
Ja gut, also noch mache ich, dass man nicht so norddeutsch, wie man das normalerweise machen würde und sehr negativ da drauf schauen. Ich kenne das ja. Ich weiß ja ganz genau, wenn ich mal bei den Fans so quer lese und dann immer denke, da bricht die Welt jetzt wieder komplett zusammen. Soweit würde ich jetzt tatsächlich noch nicht gehen. Man muss sich auch mal anschauen, was waren das für Gegner. Du hast Preußen Münster ja gerade schon erwähnt. Gut, für die war das ein besonderes Spiel auch als Aufsteiger. Das war jetzt kein besonders gutes Spiel. Aber beispielsweise verloren bei Fortuna Düsseldorf haben wir eingangs hier im Rasenfunk in dieser Folge angesprochen mit einer der Aufstiegskandidaten. Klar, mit dem muss sich 96 auch messen lassen dann am Ende. Das war ein schweres Spiel und es war auch nur ein 0 zu 1. Beim SC Paderborn war 96 nicht mal zwingend das schlechtere Team. Hatte wirklich viele Torchancen. Hat diese Möglichkeit nicht genutzt. Da kommen wir gleich zum nächsten Problem. Denn was ein großes Ding ist bislang in dieser saison, ist tatsächlich, dass 96 das Tor nicht trifft. Obwohl die Ausrichtung durchaus offensiv ist und durchaus auch auf Ballbesitz ausgerichtet ist. Ist das ein großes Problem bislang? Und dann muss man mal wieder auf die Heimspiele schauen und sieht dann da, okay, da war auch kaiserslautern dabei oder der 1. FC Nürnberg, der selbst noch in der Findungsphase ist unter dem neuen trainer Miroslav Klose. Aber eben auch der HSV und den HSV hat 96 auch zu Hause geschlagen. Also mir ist es noch ein bisschen zu früh, um da tatsächlich zu sagen, das ist eine ganz krasse Diskrepanz in dieser saison. Und sie wird sich auch so weiter durchziehen. Und ich habe so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass der Knoten noch platzt. Und Eva, weil du das gesagt hast, mit dem Pokal, im Pokal habe ich jetzt, und das kann ich jetzt mal ganz privat sagen, eigentlich schon die Hoffnung aufgegeben in den letzten Jahren. Weil 96 ist ja auch in der letzten saison in der ersten Runde rausgeflogen. Jörn, ich habe für dich recherchiert gegen den KSC. Du wusstest ja, wann war das? 2019, 2020 in der ersten Runde. Und auch sonst, die letzten Jahre, auch nie über die zweite Runde hinausgekommen. Also Pokal und 96, das war mal 1992 wunderschön. Aber danach dann auch lange Zeit einfach gar nicht mehr. Und da brauchen wir uns auch nichts vormachen, dass das irgendwann noch mal anders wird. Aber in der Liga bin ich tatsächlich gar nicht so typisch Norddeutsch. Immer noch guter Dinge.
Ja, also ich werde mich nicht beschweren beim Pokal. Weil sie haben ja in Bielefeld gespielt. Und da werde ich mich, werde ich einen Teufel tun und mich beschweren, dass sie hier verloren haben. Da bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ja, aber lass mal kurz auf die Offensive gucken. Also, ich glaube, der prominenteste Neuzugang ist der Jessica Langkamp von Eintracht Frankfurt. Durchaus ja ein sehr interessanter Spieler. Hat bis jetzt ein Tor in acht Spielen gemacht. Ich finde ihn super interessant. Also ich habe ihn, wie gesagt, ich habe Hannover in Düsseldorf gesehen. Ich sah es so schön an der Mittellinie. Das heißt, man hat auch wirklich immer so den leicht taktischen Blick auf die Sachen. Aber ich finde, also, again, ohne das jetzt hier komplett die Untergangsstimmung zu machen, aber ich finde er ist zum Teil ein bisschen stellvertretend für diese Probleme, die eben Hannover in der Offensive macht. Weil er macht ganz, ganz viel richtig. Aber diese Momente vorm Tor, dieser letzte Abschluss, da habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, da will er doch einen Tick zu viel. Also das ist manchmal noch so ein bisschen fehlt.
Ja, es kann vielleicht natürlich auch seine Geschichte sein. Er war ja vorher, bevor die Frankfurtsache war, die Zeit, die er jetzt in Frankfurt verbracht hat und dann die Leih zum FSV mainz, bei Hertha BSC unter Vertrag. Und da hatte man immer das Gefühl, er ist ein bisschen hinterhergehangen. Also kam nicht so wirklich rein, war nie wirklich Stammspieler. Und er hat ja jetzt auch keine gute letzte saison gehabt. Ich hatte extra noch mal geschaut, nämlich jetzt, bevor ich zu euch hier reingekommen bin, in den Rasenfunk. 23 Pflichtspiele, 3 Tore, eine Vorlage. Aber der ist halt wahnsinnig oft eingewechselt worden. Also auch da war das eine komplett unveränderte Lage für ihn. Und ich habe immer den Eindruck, wenn ich ihn spielen sehe bei 96, er will. Er will und will und will. Und Stefan Leitel scheint sich dessen auch bewusst zu sein, dass er sieht, okay, es könnte dieser Moment kommen, wo das funktioniert, mit dem Jessica in Gang kam. Und das ist ihm auch zu gönnen, weil ich finde, er haut sich halt total rein. Eva, du hast es genau richtig gesagt. Du merkst halt, er treibt auch mit an und er hat auch hin und wieder wirklich schöne Einzelaktionen mit drin. Aber es ist dann manchmal doch zu ungestümt. Und das hängt ihm noch so ein bisschen nach, wie so ein Rucksack, den er einfach mitgenommen hat. Jetzt für diese einjährige laie, die er in Hannover vereinbart ist, ja, muss man mal gucken. Aber ansonsten, so die Offensive an sich, ist ja nicht total interessant bestückt. Also mit Icola Tresoldi, der bei 96 ja auch mit groß geworden ist, was wirklich schön ist. Und dann mit jemandem, den du ja auch noch aus Bielefeld gut kennst, Monjo Tadeos Taddle Momono. Ich muss den ganzen Namen vorlesen, weil ich es so sensationell finde. Und weil der Typ einfach sensationell ist. Also dem guckst du gerne zu beim Spielen, ja? Und das ist jemand, von dem verspreche ich mir, dass der in dieser saison noch wirklich begeistert wird. Und ich hoffe auch, er bleibt dann auch über die saison hinaus. Denn der könnte so ein Fall sein für mich, wo die anderen mal drauf gucken. Tipps, die ein bisschen besser gestellt sind. Oder wo der Schwung dann auch irgendwann da ist. Vielleicht dann noch mal ein bisschen höher. 22 Jahre alt ist er ja erst. Und das ist auch etwas, was ich zum Beispiel wahnsinnig spannend finde bei 96, dass da doch mittlerweile drauf geschaut wird. Leute aus der Region auch mal hochzuziehen. Weil wir kennen ja auch immer das, was über 96 gesagt wurde, gerade von außen. Ach, die roten, graue Maus. Martin Kind hat immer gesagt, ja, wir wollen eine internationale Marke werden. Und ich habe schon vor ganz vielen Jahren gesagt, aber warum wollen wir denn nicht eigentlich eine schöne, regionale Marke sein? Warum nehmen wir nicht das mit, was 96 ist? Einfach auch dieses Herzliche, dieses Grüne, was man ja ganz oft einfach nicht sieht. Warum denn eigentlich nicht? Und ich finde, das merkst du. Und jetzt mache ich den Step noch mal weiter. Stefan Leitel versteht es auch, diese jungen Spieler gut zu installieren und ihnen Raum zu geben. Zu wissen, okay, das sind vielleicht junge Leute, die einfach noch ein bisschen Zeit brauchen hier und da und die auch mal ihre Tiefs haben. Aber ich glaube, er managt das unterm Strich ganz gut. Nichtsdestotrotz, am Ende, Eva, 96 möchte gerne aufsteigen, muss ja irgendwann auch wieder aufsteigen. Es ist das große Ziel. Und da kannst du natürlich mit so einer Torflaute nicht durchziehen, aber auch da. Wir sind noch relativ früh in der saison und ich glaube, da kann tatsächlich noch viel passieren und wird hoffentlich auch.
Jörn sagt gerne.
Also für mich war ja 96 zum Beispiel letztes Jahr immer so ein bisschen Schlagdistance mit ein, zwei Siegen mehr. Hättest du nach oben noch mal irgendwie hinreichen können. Denkst du irgendwie auch, weil aktuell ist, ich hab gerade, während du erzählt hast, darüber nachgedacht, totale Black Box für mich, irgendwie Hannover. Denkst du, die sind einen Schritt weiter als letztes Jahr? Kann man das irgendwie vergleichen?
Das ist ganz schwer zu sagen, weil in der letzten saison waren halt einfach diese Schwankungen extrem da, wo du immer gedacht hast, die Anlagen sind da, wurde aber einfach nicht komplett durchgezogen. Und das ist ganz schwer zu sagen, weil ich glaube, es kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, wie groovt sich 96 jetzt so in den nächsten Wochen ein. Du hast jetzt diese Startphase einfach hinter dich gebracht. Und du hast es ja beim KSC auch eingangs so ein bisschen erzählt. Auch bei 96 gab es ja Abgänge, die kompensiert werden mussten. Es waren jetzt nicht so krass viele, aber mit einem Cedric Teuchert, der wirklich gut funktioniert hat vorne in der Offensive, mit der er gegangen ist, Bride Ariemme hinten in der Defensive. Riesenspieler, wo alle gesagt haben, hoffentlich bleibt er, hoffentlich geht er nicht. Ja, der ist jetzt auch weg.
Schön.
Und da hat 96 aber auf der anderen Seite ja die Stabilität behalten. Wenn wir jetzt von Weiterentwicklung sprechen, sagen wir, okay, damit können wir auf jeden Fall auftrumpfen. Als einer der Aufstiegskandidaten, der 96 gerne sein möchte, die defensive Stabilität, die ist ja auf jeden Fall da. Gerade ist das große Problem, wie bekommst du das, was eigentlich schön aussieht, vorne hin? Und keine Ahnung, warum es nach wie vor einfach so ein bisschen hakt, weil wenn man sich die Spiele anguckt, sieht man ja, die Torschancen sind ja da. Es ist ja nicht so, dass 96 nichts rausspielen würde. Ich glaube, es ist jetzt einfach eine Frage der Zeit, ob das jetzt irgendwann in den nächsten Spielen passiert. Denn lass noch mal vier, fünf Spiele ins Land gehen und lass es so weiterlaufen. Ich glaube, dann kommt auch langsam immer mehr die Unruhe. Das ist halt leider so ein Hannover-Phänomen, was da auch nicht ganz loswirst. Martin Kind hat sich ja, glaube ich, auch schon nach diesem Niedersachsen-Therapie jetzt gleich zu Wort gemeldet und gesagt, wie das gelaufen ist, das kann ja nicht ganz verstehen hier. Dann weißt du immer schon so, ach, ja, schwierig, wenn er das jetzt schon sagt. Dann schielst du so auf den trainer und denkst, hoffentlich läuft das dann alles noch. Ich würde 96 eigentlich tatsächlich, um so eine Einschätzung zu machen, gerne noch die drei, vier, fünf Wochen geben, um zu gucken, sind das jetzt nur Startschwierigkeiten oder ist das wirklich ein festgewachsenes Problem, was dann irgendwann im Kopf auch fest ist?
Also generell finde ich halt schon angenehm, sage ich mal so von außen, dass man halt wirklich jetzt mal über längere Zeit auch an einem trainer durchaus mit einem Plan, mit Stefan Nathen festgehalten hat, weil auch das war ja ein riesengroßes Problem bei 96. Also ich erinnere mich noch an Slomka-Zeiten etc., wo man sich zwischendurch dachte, so um Gottes willen, wo rennt ihr gerade hinterher? Also ich finde schon allein dieser Weg, den finde ich schon sehr angenehm, von außen zu beobachten. Nur ich könnte mir halt auch vorstellen, weil wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, sind wir jetzt in diesem dritten Jahr, was damals so ein bisschen ausgerufen wurde bei der Leitl-Verpflichtung. Also ich fand damals ja schon richtig, dass sie nicht gesagt haben, hier ein neuer trainer, der ist mit Fynn mal aufgestiegen hier, wir wollen jetzt aufsteigen, direkt diese saison, dass man schon, und ich meine, sind wir mal ganz ehrlich, das musst du als Hannover 96 auch irgendwann die Anforderungen stellen, wir wollen zurück in die Bundesliga. So und wir sehen diese saisons, da gibt es die größeren Vereine, die eben die Jahre, wo eben Stuttgart und Co. abgestiegen sind, auch in Hannover mit abgestiegen sind, wo sich eigentlich so die Ausstiegsplätze relativ von alleine ausstellen, sage ich mal, auf jeden Fall von außen. Und dann hast du so Jahre wie diese, wo die Absteiger mit Darmstadt und Köln, Köln auch gerade mit dieser Transfersperre etc., vielleicht nicht so die klassischen Vereine sind, die man dann direkt wieder als Aufsteiger hoch tippt. Und das sind ja eigentlich diese saisons, wo man sagt, okay, da müssen jetzt die Schalkes und Düsseldorfs und Nürnbergs und Hannovers dieser Welt, also die von, die für viele ja immer noch diese, ich weiß nicht, ich sag immer 2009er Sportschau so ein bisschen sind, ne? Die müssen da eigentlich wieder rein. Und das finde ich, also dass man jedenfalls den Anspruch hat, das finde ich komplett legitim. Ich finde auch gut, dass man sagt, auch jetzt in dieser saison bekommt er wieder Zeit. Ich kann aber auf der anderen Seite auch Fans verstehen, wenn sie irgendwann sagen, gut, aber irgendwo ist dann ja auch die Geduld durch, also auch auf Fan-Seite. Wir wollen gerne einen Kontinu... Also das hat Jörn eben angesprochen, Kontinuität, Entwicklung, eben das haben wir gesehen. Frank Schmidt, ja wirklich bestes Beispiel, wie lange Zeit man ihm, ich sag mal, gegeben hat, um in die Bundesliga aufzusteigen und was er jetzt mit Heidenheim macht. Dieses immer wieder, dieses Thema. Nimmt Tränen auch mal das dritte oder vierte Jahr geben, aber ich verstehe auch schon, wenn da irgendwann bei Hannover das auch irgendwie endet. Und da dann halt, also siehst du denn realistisch, dass Hannover da vielleicht auch mit ein, zwei Transfers vielleicht noch in der Winterpause, um da nachzulegen? In der Offensive eventuell sogar auch. Siehst du denn, dass sie dann da bis am Ende oben mitspielen können?
Ich finde, das Potenzial ist da. Du hast ja ganz viel Richtiges gerade auch gesagt, so dieses typische, wir nehmen jetzt mal die großen Vereine, die Traditionsvereine, zu denen ich 96 natürlich auch zähle, und hauen die Namen einfach mal oben raus und sagen, die marschieren jetzt. Das ist ja nun mal wirklich auch nicht so. Also auf Schalke fragen sie sich auch wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit, was tun wir hier? Der HSV ist jetzt noch glücklich gerade, aber Ostern wird kommen. Ja, und dann werden sie sich auch alle nochmal umdrehen. Ich will es gar nicht jinxen, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Es ist halt eine ganz schwierige Kiste und Geschichte. Und mein Mann, der ist großer FC-Fan, der hat auch zu mir gesagt, ja, das ist ganz toll. Weißt du, offensiv ist das super und defensiv ist das einfach wirklich schlecht. Gerade oder schlecht ist immer ein ganz, ganz böses Wort. Ist das nicht gut aktuell? Deshalb, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, die ist groß und 96, glaube ich, wird zeigen müssen, ob genug individuelle Qualität einfach auch da ist. Und ich finde, die ist im Kader. Du musstest ja dann auch über die ganze saison spielen. Das darfst du nicht vergessen. Also guck dir die Vereine an, die jetzt da gerade oben sind. Und ich möchte Düsseldorf da wirklich explizit rausnehmen, weil ich glaube, die haben einfach, die sind bei sich. Die sind komplett beisammen. Und die sehe ich da auch oben und die werden auf jeden Fall bis zum Ende da oben auch mitspielen. Beim SC Paderborn, ja, die haben mir auch gefallen jetzt in der Anfangsphase. Kann ich es aber nicht sagen, ob es wirklich so ist beim KSC. Jörn, ja, du hast ja erzählt, was gut läuft, was aber auch nicht gut läuft. Da muss man auch gucken, wobei das auch in der letzten saison bei auch einer der Kandidaten durchaus hätten oben weiter mitmachen können und dann doch irgendwo Richtung Platz 3 kratzen können, so ein bisschen. Ich sehe das bei 96 und ich finde es gut, Eva, du hast es angesprochen, dass da wirklich mal ein bisschen Ruhe reingekommen ist auf dieser trainerposition. Musste mich wirklich auch selber so ein bisschen kratzen, dass ich gesehen habe. In Stefan Leitl geht erstmal seit zehn Jahren ein 96-Coach in seine dritte saison in Hannover. Seit zehn Jahren. Das muss man sich mal reinziehen. Also da weißt du dann halt, was los ist. Aber ich habe auch gegen Ende der letzten saison mit Kollegen von der Hannoverischen Presse gesprochen und habe dann da auch rausgehört, dass auch nicht alles so ganz, ganz sicher war, dass sie natürlich auf diesen Dreijahresplan geguckt haben und nicht klar war, will man dann wirklich, traut man das Stefan Leithel von der Vereinsspitze wirklich zu oder auch nicht. Und dann waren ja auch andere trainerstellen, wie ihr wisst, in der 2. Liga vakant. Man wusste zum Beispiel bei Hertha, Pall Darday wird aufhören, wird gehen. Das war dann so die ganze Zeit am Ende und die Stelle, die war dann offen. Der hat dann jetzt doch Christian Fell bekommen. Ich bin ganz froh, dass Stefan Leithel geblieben ist, weil auch für mich als gebürtige Hannoveranerin, die in Berlin wohnt und immer auch viel von außen draufschaut, strahlt dieser Mann eine Ruhe aus. Ich habe das Gefühl, der weiß ganz genau, dass er auch seine Spieler abschirmen muss von dem Rest und so. Und da baue ich so ein bisschen drauf und glaube, dass diese ganze Mischung dazu beitragen kann, dass 96 bis zum Ende obendran bleiben kann. Ob es dann für ganz oben reicht, das wird sich zeigen. Für mich wäre das eher so ein Kandidat für die Relegation. Wer 96 in diesem Jahr für mich. Das Böse erbarte. Alles, was wir nicht wollen.
Ich glaube, ich könnte übrigens nicht aufzählen, wann mein Verein letztes Mal einen trainer hatte, der die dritte saisonfolge gemacht hat. Ich glaube, gefühlt noch nie. Vielleicht irgendwann mal ernst mit dem Dorf, bevor er irgendwelche PressemitarbeiterInnen beleidigt hat. Einen Satz wollte ich noch zu Mumulu sagen, den finde ich tatsächlich sehr interessant. Er war, wie gesagt, letzte saison an Bielefeld ausgeliehen. Genauso wie ein Marius Wörl. Beide wollte Bielefeld eigentlich halten. Gerade bei Mumulu war es ein langer Kampf. Er sollte, glaube ich, auch nach Polen oder in die Niederlande verliehen werden. Er ist dann in Hannover geblieben. Bei Hannover ist ja auch nochmal die Sondersituation, dass man Hannover 2 in der 3. Liga hat. Übrigens immer noch meine Lieblingsstory, dass wenn Hannover 1 absteigen sollte, darf Hannover 2 aufsteigen. Und dann hätte man die U23-Mannschaft in der 2. Liga und die Profimannschaft der 3. Liga. Herrliche Story. Hoffen wir natürlich alle nicht, dass das so kommt. Aber das finde ich auch durchaus interessant. Also eben das, was du sagst. Der hat zwei Tore in vier Spielen gemacht. Der zeigt wirklich super viel Engagement und der ist super gut in dieser Liga angekommen. Und Stefan Leidel sieht das und sagt dann so, ja, und jetzt spielst du auch. Weil du gehörtest vielleicht nicht zu meinem Plan am Anfang der saison, aber das gehörst du jetzt. Und das finde ich durchaus auch interessant von außen zu beobachten. Er hat mir sehr, sehr gut– ich glaube, Enzo Leopold ist auch so immer jemand, der immer auch die, die so, also das waren auch die Zwei-Spieler, die mir am besten gefallen haben im Spiel gegen Braunschweig. Aber Zwei-Spieler oder können halt nicht so alleine so eine ganze Mannschaft, ja, durchziehen, sag ich mal.
Aber dann hast du ja auch noch die erfahrenen mit dabei, ne, darfst du auch nicht vergessen, ob das jetzt ein Ron Robert Ziele ist, der mittlerweile so lange mit Unterbrechungen in Hannover im Tor steht, dass der ganz genau weiß, wie tickt dieser Verein, wie tickt auch diese Stadt, was kann ich denen, die dazukommen, die neu sind hier, mit an die Hand geben, ja, was hab ich schon erlebt alles mit diesem Verein. Dann auch zum Beispiel Marcel Halzenberg. Ich fand das super, ja, als der nach Hannover gekommen ist, und das hatte ja dann ganz unterschiedliche Gründe, aber fand dann auch in der letzten saison, konnte ich ihn mal 90 Minuten wirklich im Stadion gegen Hertha BSC beobachten. Was für eine Bossrolle, der eingenommen hat einfach in diesem Team, ja, was du merkst auch einfach, wie der die anderen mitziehen kann, das sind ganz, ganz wichtige Säulen, ja, in diesem System. Der Christian Sön ist jetzt fit im Mittelfeld, ist auch nochmal eine ganz andere Komponente vorne. Da haben wir jetzt wenige aufgezählt, aber da gibt es ja auch noch mehrere Optionen, ja, mit dem erfahrenen Havard Nielsen zum Beispiel. Also du hast ja einen breiten Kader, der eigentlich echt gut– was ist das für ein Gesichtsausdruck gerade gewesen, Eva? Was war das für ein Gedanke, der dir gerade den Kopf geschossen ist?
Andreas Vogelsammer mit Fabi Kunze, Max Christensen, der ist auch noch da, genau. Geht einfach so durch die Liste.
Genau. Aber es ist halt tatsächlich so, dass ich finde, dass dieser Kader doch sehr breit bestückt ist und auch sehr mit Charakteren, die sehr viele unterschiedliche Fähigkeiten mitbringen. Und das ist etwas, da sollte man aus Fällensicht, glaube ich, nicht so negativ mit umgehen, weil das ist etwas Wertvolles, das zu haben. Und im Großen und Ganzen, du hast halt einfach denselben trainer. Du musst keinen Neustart jetzt irgendwo wagen. Das ist auch nochmal etwas, was eine Rolle spielt. Guckt euch Hertha BSC an. Ich weiß es ja hier aus erster Hand. Die wollen natürlich auch aufsteigen und die müssen jetzt wieder im Grunde genommen bei Null anfangen, indem sie erst mal ein neues Spielsystem reinkriegen. Ja, egal wie toll der Kader bestückt ist oder egal, wie toll die Neuverpflichtungen sind und das ist erst mal ein hartes Stück Arbeit, das irgendwie durchzukriegen. Merkst du, dass dann da auch nochmal ganz andere Startschwierigkeiten sind? Nee, von daher für mich 96 mit wirklich, mit einem wirklich interessanten Kader, auch wen ich noch vergessen habe, Janik Rochelt, den sie geholt haben, den finde ich auch spannend. Also es ist da, da sind wirklich viele, viele interessante Charaktere dabei.
Ja, und das ist, ich glaube, eine Sache, die Stefan Neidl definitiv geschafft hat, ist eben auch das Niedersachsen-Stadion wieder zu füllen mit Fans. Also das war ja auch durchaus eine Zeitlang ein Problem und er hat das zumindest wieder geschafft. Und ich glaube, das war, also und die Heimspiele, die gewinnen sie dann ja auch. Von daher, das ist dann sicherlich auch, der Weg geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung, lasst es uns so formulieren. Zwei kurze Sachen noch, die ich jetzt einfach doch noch neben dem Platz hinterher schiebe. Ich habe ja gesagt, das spielt jetzt noch kurze Rolle, wollen wir jetzt aber nicht mehr so ausbreiten. Einmal das Thema Fan-Proteste, also nach Ausschreitungen in der letzten saison in den Derbys, hatte ja Niedersachsens Innenministerin Daniela Behrens angekündigt, dass beide Derbys ohne Gäste-Fans stattfinden sollten. Erst Anfang September, nachdem dann auch Braunschweig einen neuen Plan vorgelegt hatte, wie dieses Derby ablaufen könnte. Fehlernahe Entscheidung, dass das Derby zwar mit Gäste-Fans stattfindet, allerdings, dass das Gäste-Kontingent um 40 Prozent reduziert wird. Und es unter anderem auch einen Intro- und Kuriumaterialienverbot geben würde, intensivere Einlasskontrollen, verschärfte Video-Filme. Und daraufhin hat Hannovers Fanszene verkündet, dass sie das Derby boykottieren. Das verfügbare Kontingent wurde auch bei Weitem nicht ausgeschöpft. Ich glaube, 50 Prozent oder so hieß es am Ende. Und eben auch die Braunschweiger-Fanszene hat sich quasi solidarisiert. Auch das ist durchaus ein besonderes Zeichen. Und kündigte zwar an, anwesend zu sein, aber nicht zu supporten, eben weil das ein Eingriff in die Fan-Kultur ist. Und beide Fanszenen hatten dann Demonstrationen angemeldet, am 3. Oktober, am letzten Donnerstag, durch die gegenseitigen Städte, also Hannover in Braunschweig, Braunschweig in Hannover, eben unter der Thematik Populismus entgegentreten für eine freie Fan-Kultur in Niedersachsen und anderswo. Da ist auch alles relativ friedlich verlaufen. Fand ich aber irgendwie dann durchaus doch so ein Novum, dass man sich da so solidarisiert. Und das letzte, was ich gelesen habe, war bei Daniela Behrens selber nicht im Stadion am Sonntag. Das kann man dann auch bewerten, wie man möchte. Weil eben auch gesagt wurde, sollte es da jetzt auch mal Ausschreitungen geben, dann werden eben die nächsten, da bist definitiv ohne Gäste-Fans stattfinden. Für das Rückspiel muss jetzt Hannover ein eigenes Sicherheitskonzept vorlegen. Also das wird immer neu bewertet. Und ja, also generell hat Behrens noch gesagt, die vielen Rückmeldungen aus der Bevölkerung sprechen da eine eindeutige Sprache, dass die Mehrheit der Stadionbesucher sich massiv verunsichert fühlt. Und für die Sicherheit im Stadion sind die Vereine verantwortlich. Die Verantwortung dafür kann nicht von der Polizei wahrgenommen werden. Gut, also ich glaube, es ist eine Thematik. Deshalb haben wir das jetzt so ein bisschen kürzer gemacht. Ich glaube, da könnte man alleine eine halbe Stunde darüber diskutieren, was das alles mit sich zieht. Aber generell finde ich, also wir haben eben auch schon mal über Karlsruhe gesprochen. Auch da gab es sehr viel Solidarität, eben über die Grenzen hinaus, eben mit der organisierten Szene, aber eben auch mit den Fanprojekten. Und auch hier natürlich wieder, also wenn zwei sich wirklich sehr verfeindete Fans sehen, miteinander solidarisieren, weil sie sagen, ey, wir können zwar auf den Tod nicht ausstehen, aber ein Derby ist halt nur Derby, wenn wirklich beide Fans sehen, auch irgendwie anwesend sind und ihr Ding machen können. Das fand ich schon durchaus bemerkenswert. Und dann noch eine letzte Sache, weil Kind schwebt immer ein bisschen im Raum. Aber ich glaube auch da, ich glaube, da könnte man wahrscheinlich drei Tribünengespräche mit erfüllen. Deshalb da auch nur ganz kurz. Seit, ich glaube, gestern ist Martin Kinds Sohn Matthias nicht mehr Teil des Aufsichtsrats bei Hannover 96. Und viel wichtiger vom BGH-Urteil vom 16. Juli diesen Jahres. Martin Kind ist nicht mehr Geschäftsführer von Hannover 96. Die Abberufung von vor zwei Jahren war also rechtskräftig. Es ist aber wirklich, ich sage es euch ganz ehrlich, sowohl Steffi als auch mir fehlt einfach juristisch das Background-Wissen, um das vernünftig zu erklären. Und ich würde mich da auch nicht wohlfühlen, da einfach irgendwelche anderen Sätze oder anderen journalistischen Mitteln einfach komplett abzulesen, weil das müsste ich am Ende des Tages machen. Da ist einfach meine, ja, mein Verständnis für es da leider zu gering. Und das könnte ich da nicht so richtig rüberbringen. Ich kann aber so viel sagen, vom Aufsichtsratvorsitzenden des EV wurde im kompletten Verlauf unter anderem der DFB und die DFL für mangelnde Unterstützung des Muttervereins kritisiert, Thema 50 plus 1. Und man sagt auch, so richtig traut man dem Rat noch nicht, dass da ihm die Ruhe einkehrt, also kein Grund zu feiern. Und ich würde euch tatsächlich ausnahmsweise mal einen Artikel von 11 Freunde in den Show Notes verlinken, wo eben ja das nochmal aufgedröselt wird, wie es um Hannover nach diesem BGH-Ruhe-Teil steht. So, so viel neben dem Platz. Ich habe es jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen abgekürzt. Ich hoffe, das ist für alle Leute in Ordnung. Hannover 96 wird sicherlich nochmal vorkommen und dann können wir es sicherlich nochmal vertiefen. Aber sowohl Steffi als auch mir war es heute einfach mal wichtig, auf das Sportliche zu gucken, weil da gibt es ja genug zu bezählen. Gut, möchtet ihr beide noch was zum Sportlichen zu euren Vereinen loswerden? Das scheint nicht so. Stille.
Wunschlussglücklich.
Das ist schön. Dann von mir noch zwei Sachen. Einmal habe ich Podcast-Empfehlungen für euch dabei. Und zwar die erste. Gestern war der 7. Oktober und Max, also ein Jahr nach dem Angriff der Hamas auf das Nova-Festival und Max hatte im vergangenen Jahr, glaube ich, schon mit Felix Tamsut über die Situation gesprochen. Und ich finde, das ist bis heute ein sehr schönes Tribünengespräch. Hört da gerne noch mal rein. Das verlinke ich euch. Und dann von Feminist Shelf Control. Die haben eine Episode rausgebracht. Unter anderem, die ja den Prozess in Frankreich thematisiert, über die Massenvergewaltigung, die da stattgefunden hat. Und ja, auch über diverse Themen, über das Patriarchat, etc. Ich fand es eine sehr hörenswerte Folge. Daher würde ich euch das auch einmal in die Show notes packen. Wer möchte, kann sich das gerne anhören. Und dann sind wir am Ende dieser Folge. Das heißt, als allererstes möchte ich da unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern danken. Dieser Podcast ist und bleibt Paywall, Werbe- und Sponsorenfrei. Dieser Podcast wird finanziert durch euch, lebt durch euch. Ihr könnt euch informieren über rasenfunk-supporters.club, wie das funktioniert. Ihr finanziert damit die schönen Gäste, die hier sitzen. Ihr finanziert aber eben auch das Marc und ich hier jetzt sitzen. Und ein stellvertretender Dank geht dafür an Highlord Alarak, LordMods Ferdinand, Bernhard, Dominik und Meti85. Ihr seid Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Vielen, vielen Dank dafür. Guckt auch gerne vorbei. Wir haben so viele Formate. Ich glaube, was hier schon wieder alles rausgekommen ist, ich glaube, übermorgen erscheint ein Schwerpunkt zum VfW Bochum. Und dann würde ich mich jetzt bei meinen Gästen bedanken. Vielen Dank Steffi, dass du dabei warst.
Sehr gerne, hat ganz viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich und lieben Dank auch Jörn aka Haus of Karlsruhe, Experte, Hofberichterstatter. Danke Jörn.
Sehr gerne und danke, dass ich dabei sein durfte.
Dann wünsche ich euch viel Spaß bei der Folge. Ich hoffe, sie hat euch Spaß gemacht.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.